[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings any parent
of a teen or tween can tell you how much
their children love watching tik tok the
video sharing site says it has 1 billion
users every single month and a lot of
those users are kids the pew research
center says half of american adults
under 30 also use tick tock not just
dance videos anymore it's involved into
a site that covers all parts of life
everything from recipes to clothing to
trending challenges and with other
social media apps getting a lot of
attention right now for their impact on
teen's mental health we wanted to take a
closer look at tick-tock
[Music]
if the video sharing platform tick-tock
was a person it would only be in
kindergarten today i'm making the viral
feta cheese and tomato pasta but in just
five short years since its launch in
2016 the chinese-born app has exploded
in popularity according to the company
more than one billion users sign on to
scroll monthly tick tock's terms and
conditions require users to be at least
13 but the company admits it has removed
millions of accounts suspected to be
under that age so what is tick-tock
showing our children
earlier this year the wall street
journal programmed dozens of bots
registered as 13 to 15 year olds to see
what videos the app's algorithms would
show them the result hundreds of videos
about drug use eating disorders and porn
site recommendations
and despite thousands of videos labeled
as for adults only the wall street
journals teenage bots still found them
meaning they could have landed in front
of the eyes of real children there are
also concerns about overuse something
nate talked about with his 11 year old
daughter mia i feel like at one point
you were addicted to tick-tock
yeah
do you think you were
definitely
there's no doubt and when nate asked mia
how often she uses the app he said her
answer was eye-opening
do you want the truth yeah
um about
more than eight hours a day probably
eight hours a day yeah when you don't
find anything on it you'll still want to
look for things that'll make you happy
tick tock told the wall street journal
protecting minors is vitally important
and tick tock has taken industry first
steps to promote a safe and age
appropriate experience for teens close
quote michael beckerman tick tock's head
of public policy for north america
is here with us now to talk more about
all of this michael thank you for being
here
we just heard nate's daughter say she
uses tick tock for eight hours a day
which sounds like a pretty big number to
me and i think we should start there
with the overarching question of how
tick-tock can make an experience that is
dependent on taking more and more and
more of our children's attention
and do it ethically
it's a great question tick-tock is about
entertainment and bringing joy we put a
premium on authentic content uplifting
content
but like all entertainment you want to
watch with moderation and and we put
tools in place take a break videos
screen time management um and tools for
parents like family pairing to make sure
that they can have conversations and and
do what's right for their family and
their teenagers so we should talk about
some of those tools but i want to pause
for a second to bring in the china
component of this i know there's a lot
of misinformation about
tick tock in china but one thing that is
very interesting to american parents is
the fact that tick tock's version in
china owned by your parent company by
dance same logo many of the same
features
they have voluntarily capped use for 14
and under uh kids at 40 minutes per day
no overnight use and by the way all the
content is going to be educational
according to the company if that's what
they're doing over there why is the
experience so different for our kids
well first off tick-tock is not
available in china and so i can't speak
necessarily the same logo same uh
platform it's over there with your
company they have a different policy for
their kids why do our kids get exposed
yeah tick tock is completely separate
from from that and they have different
regulations and rules
in china they do in the u.s but here
we we do have an age-appropriate
experience
we have the tools in place to have um
let parents decide how much time they
want their teenagers to spend we give
the nudge on on taking a break but it's
something that we're talking to
policymakers on it's important that apps
have age-appropriate experience and we
have certain tools actually that are not
available for younger teenagers
direct messaging for example something
that's very popular with teenagers but
also it's an area that you know bad
things can happen with indirect messages
so on tik-tok if you're under 16 there's
no direct messaging at all and so we've
we proactively put a lot of these things
in place to ensure a safer experience on
the app so tick tock sister company is
radically limiting what 14 year olds can
do and you're considering the same here
that's interesting on its face i i have
to say when i hear a social media
company say that we're nudging people to
get off the product or to use it less i
think to myself what other companies ask
customers
maybe you want to do this less and the
other companies are gambling companies
maybe tobacco companies maybe alcohol
companies what we call vice industries
what does it say about social media that
you're also asking people hey maybe you
should do this less well i think that's
a false comparison um this is
entertainment you know just like
watching tv or the radio or netflix or
anything else you should watch in
moderation we're just trying to be
responsible and and we're trying to
learn as well we've we've invested in
boston children's hospital helping them
put together a digital wellness lab
to hear from experts on on what are the
things that can be healthy for teenagers
and we're implementing that proactively
watch with moderation and watch
responsibly is almost identical to what
the alcohol industry says just saying
it's it's not you know it's not it's not
the same thing it's an entertainment
platform and again you know like cbs you
have a lot of great programming but you
don't want people to watch all day
either but we kind of do but social
media can be addictive but i i quickly
want you to explain
and define algorithm before i get to my
question because that work is thrown
around a lot and parents don't know what
it means
yeah it's a great question it's
something that shouldn't be scary um and
and for us actually we've been leading
into transparency about how the
algorithm which is the for you feed that
decides what videos that you're seeing
in your in your feed to have
transparency with policy makers and
regulators and anybody that's interested
in knowing how that works you know for
us it's interest based and so we're a
little bit different than the typical
social media companies that are based on
who you know and those social
interactions this is based on the
entertainment
and what you're watching in the app and
so as you're seeing videos and you're
engaging with those videos the things
that you find more joyful and
interesting and fun and you share with
your friends
and you like you'll get more of that
okay so with that said i understand that
concept i could walk into my daughter's
room and i could see her smiling she's
having a great experience on the app but
what if there's a day where my daughter
doesn't feel good about herself she has
a bad day at school um she is
second-guessing how she looks her
self-esteem is damaged and she falls
into this vortex
will the algorithm start to send her
videos that takes her deeper and deeper
and deeper into maybe even a depression
as long as she's interested will it take
her there so so a difference also on
tick tock is it's about a diversity of
content and so we look we look to have a
lot of different kinds of sources
information so you're not just getting
into one thing but also we have ways if
you're not interested in something you
want to see less but but also look it
starts with a conversation it's you
can't just think that you're not going
to talk to your teenager and
everything's going to be okay whether
they're online or offline for sure it
starts with conversations and we have
a guide on our website we worked with
the parent teacher association others
said like what can you do to facilitate
those conversations and one of the
things you can do is start by watching
content with your teenager or even
filming videos with them yeah it's
something that we've seen so much of
during the pandemic of parents coming
together the teenagers and that's a good
way to start a conversation really
quickly if i could my daughter's seven
all of her little friends have tick-tock
i took it off because she kept going in
and i showed her you have to be 13. so
you're lying about your age so that you
can watch the videos it makes her
incredibly happy to see people dancing
and and having fun but then she was
following people that were not
age-appropriate so are you guys at a
point where you're looking at that other
group we started off talking about teens
and tweens but clearly you're talking
seven eight nine-year-olds that are on
your platform yeah we have an experience
for uh younger users under 13 experience
where you can't post videos it's all
private um and they want that other
experience they want to be able to post
but it's input but it's if it's
important also for parents to make sure
that their teenagers are having an
age-appropriate experience and we have
that um the videos are all curated with
common sense networks and we want to
have a fun experience for everybody i
have to have to throw this out there i
trust tick-tock when my daughter is on
it um that's because i'm very active in
what she watches um you know i don't
want you to feel like you're being
attacked but there are questions as a
father that i'm concerned about and i
appreciate you answering them yeah we're
honestly here and and i love that
takeaway please scroll responsibly
tick tock michael beckerman thank you
very much thank you appreciate you being
on please come back too this is a good
conversation i want to really go in
absolutely